we have an unhelpful advice Gil Gil go
stories with Bobby
kalila after last week so many people
want you guys to answer their paranormal
experiences because you guys are experts
a long time listener thought I'd share
my ghost story with you I'm a dirty old
dude who does not believe in any of that
whoo-whoo [ __ ] however my young
nephew keeps mentioning that we believe
Oh what we believe is just an imaginary
friend but he refers to him as the man
with the snake neck he's mentioned him
couple times in usually at night if you
press him for more information he'll
eventually just respond that he doesn't
know where he came from but that he
lives in the basement and comes through
a hole in the floor he's referring to
the air-conditioning vent in the
hardwood floor of my sister's house
generally I'd say this is just some
twisted imagination of a young child
under six but the last time I babysat
him at around 2:00 a.m. after the nephew
was sleeping I swear to you I could hear
steady knocking coming from the basement
steps they eventually stopped on their
own after I refused to investigate by
myself the next morning my freaky nephew
asked if I saw the man with the snake
neck last night when he came to visit
needless to say I immediately pant
planned on cutting that kid out of my
life ASA yes but do you think yes cut
him out do you think I'm overreacting or
do kids actually see things that we
cannot also what the [ __ ] does snake
neck mean love you guys that's the show
jaw it's like the no neck lady in the
end the hunting of Hill House I'm sorry
the bent neck lady I'll tell you why
yeah my opinion my expert opinion in
these paranormal activities you know in
is is that when a child sees an
imaginary friend mm-hmm but I don't
think it's an imagined I think I think
it's a when they see the boogeyman sure
or their or they're fearful of the
creature down below right it's usually
there's something down there or I saw a
shadow or I feel something or you know
but when you when you get specific and
you see the neck and you'd see reptile
scales right snake neck and that's also
very like
it's not descriptive it's odd it's an
odd thing to describe why do if that was
my son I would move and he would have to
stay there in the house oh no you know
what I would do I would be like I was
boarding school oh yeah not removing
from me
Oh like pretend for social for social
reasons no you know he's in Switzerland
going to you know I mean the Academy
like really does it come on for somebody
no it's it's it's a year-round thing but
what if what if the young kid is the
snake charmer and so he's the only one
that can control the snake and maybe
keep it keep it a friendly snake neck
monster whether whether he could control
it or whether it's a [ __ ] monster I
don't want that [ __ ] in my life why it
could be an ally oh that's true like not
all not all ghosts Cadman casper exists
also like that we also there's an
intruder right you hear the [ __ ]
glass I mean and people coming in you go
to your son right and it comes out all
dads
it's a weapon [ __ ] it's like amazing
Let The Right One In remember how
eventually she protected the boy from
like being bullied and stuff mm-hmm I
wanted to read this thing remember how
last week during our paranormal session
of talking about the pink flowers around
the pale yellow house somebody sent me
what they found on the internet about
what those pink flowers that Kadena Dam
more symbolized do you want to hear it
symbolize remember the yellow house your
everything I can't forget it okay okay
it says then add a more Kadena damar a
flower from Mexico and our widespread
throughout the Philippines on the
surface they are vines a beautiful pink
and white flowers and that is why they
are named chain of love and sometimes
Brides tears as a flower resembles tiny
hearts and chains
however they earn a unlucky our negative
connotation since they flourished so
strongly that they over
and choke out their surroundings they
are often commonly found in graveyards
constantly needing to be eradicated as
they eventually cover and consume entire
headstones and graveyards oh my [ __ ]
god
so they choke out their surroundings and
my whole house was surrounded by that
you need to eradicate them yeah your
memories the honest truth about the kid
with a snake neck monster yeah
the honest truth is is probably he he
might have gone through something
traumatic right and he made you know and
and this snake neck creature you know I
mean is something that he came up with
the deal with you know I mean this
tragedy or he could just have a very
creative imagination and you know I bet
you money if you had talked to Stephen
King or was a Clive Barker or or any
like you know horror movie what I just a
Clive Barker reference just made me
giggle I don't know why a Clive Barker
and you know any horror movie you know
novelist RL Stein yeah they might have
you know grown up and had these kind of
imaginary things and maybe that's just a
part of their maybe he's gonna become a
great writer because that is a very
creative you know kind of creature a
statement dude and you know honestly
little boys are funny man my friend just
sent me a video of her son like clamping
his own dick with magnets and he I
that's she was like do you think there's
something wrong with him and I honestly
think he's like ahead of his time and
just onto something that we're not aware
of but he he's like these things have
electricity and he's like clamping he's
growing it I don't know what it was but
it was something I'm proud of him I'm
like wow that's he's taking risks in
life and wow what a what a great kid
taking risk like who just clamps their
own [ __ ] dick down cuz if I saw that
if your own son did that well first of
all I'd have to catch him all right does
it there's two things whatever a secret
about it okay there's two there that
right there are two scenarios there's me
bring up a door and him clamping his own
dick with [ __ ] right yeah so that's not
as bad as hey Dad you want to see
something cool yeah cuz then that I'd be
like yes son I think maybe it's a little
playful joke mm-hmm you know I mean like
somebody like somebody told me this joke
was so dumb on you know that trauma Todd
who you know he makes jokes when we
played war zone and he and he did a joke
that was so dumb you know what does it
sound like when Pink Panther steps on an
ant what dead ant dead ant right that's
what he said
and that when we're playing right for
like a minute after he said the punch
line no one said anything
it was completely silence no one laughed
George we just we just kissed
we just kept playing and then and the
trauma Todd goes guys funny and we never
even we never even you know and keep our
got angry yeah I got that did that [ __ ]
you you're mean but anyway wait so if
your son came up to you said dad I would
think that he would do a good angio
right okay well I would think that he
would like to show me some sort of like
card trick he learned from his friend
Billy
yeah but he's four right he's four if he
was clamping his dick you know it's like
you know the human version of Julio our
dog and I would probably seek medical
it's psychological attention to it
that's weird I don't know I found it to
be really cute and adventurous it truly
that's what I thought I was like I love
this kid this kid is just getting to
know his body and like doing weird [ __ ]
with it and not having any shame yeah
thanks for listening to another episode
of tiger belly we really you know this
has been a tough week you know we'll see
what happens
more will be more
will be revealed yeah more will be
revealed